[Music]
[Applause]
not here it's protecting we're a lot so
make sure you're not cutting it get a
knife in her hand you would make sure
that knife stage that you wouldn't go
like this
don't drop the shoulders we're not
pulling her back so I don't hear I don't
pull that's it
so we go here and then the head controls
the spine you see well I'm not calling
the head the head was gone over I'm not
oh I confess they start to turn back
just timing enough friction with her
asset
[Music]
[Applause]
right amount of friction that you I need
them all because I don't want a pulley
energy come into me okay she comes out
come into me it's not hope just guiding
here
this has downward because at this point
she can try to turn except for I hug her
head block you see boom so the two hands
throw that mop head all the time to let
your output you tell me so that it's all
going in your knife then if you Kevin
get so bad then I don't let out okay so
[Music]
Hank do too much for me that night okay
so pay attention extension extension
compression turn boom she gets up o body
throws then without the pauses because
the pastas are crap positives are a
better mind and a fettered body for
weight distribution you can't move so
you don't have to go fast but your
hockey
you can't keep doing Q on the same way
for your whole life you must be so
traversing of some time and a travel
team of any kind means can I go from
where I was to someplace different from
where I was so what you need to do is we
progress in your training you need to
not do you to all versions you need to
think of your old versions as if they
are entirely different techniques so you
don't go Oh eat me don't get it I'm
gonna be don't do your DV nog is wrong
so don't do your you knock it just do
what we're doing now
okay so pulling is low percentage
because of the amount of external
mechanical advantage you often need and
grabbing is also low percentage because
you need grip strength and it is very
slow which is why we can do the dollar
bill trick to everyone okay so you want
to get away from pulling and graphic
because Aikido is spiral in nature when
you what you understand
as a pulling movement could be
replicated by pushing to the other side
of the circle or the spiral and that's
what we're doing now okay and what we
get from this is an integrity for the
radius the guy can't close the gap
do you understand and you don't get that
when you pull it and grab me and plus
whatever else you use from pulling and
grabbing okay so I'm not I see what you
guys are doing you're using that hand
I'm not doing that there's almost a
pushing them off balance and then I have
a lock on the head because I'm going to
give up the arm you see and the arm was
controlling them making a tighter circle
in my circle basically shortening the
radius inside my radius do you see that
we do that all the time
in Aikido so once I lose the arm there's
nothing shortening or nothing stopping
them from shortening the radius
understand pulling them into you is just
asking for it but when I lock the head
and the head cannot turn into me then I
have replicated what I was getting from
control of the neck and control of the
arm
can't you can't bring the shoulder
across
so I keep the cross model check and I
maintain the integrity of my zone
sanctuary do you guys get that okay so
because I'm not probably the first thing
you should see is I don't need to put my
thumb as an inner picture grip there was
no need for it okay then as she gets up
I don't need to drop her I just blend
with that and I don't get to here and
then go like that
I find the lock because this is the chin
won't open it up here's what I'm doing
turn your shoulder the other way there
you see it won't go and this is what I
throw with so don't go like this and put
it on your shoulder before you got there
so you already turn inside you
just keep her off by lunch so you think
Kazushi here wool and the log is right
there
you see how to already started turning
now if you ask you ask announcer you
filled my palm heel on your head is it
pulling or pushing push do you see that
I'm gonna exaggerate it you see it's
this way
if you see poha it's going this way keep
the lock
yeah move your body once apex you'll
feel it
that's when you say qualities of grace
and power ended young to tell you okay
so I don't have to kill my training
[Music]
so you in fighting a fight to control
your head polyadenylated okay that's why
don't have there so all the mad fun
Neko Toscani you know details up you're
just doing the heart is fine but it
won't work by English ponytail okay so a
lot of times when we go to the center
ring so I have my arm ray elbow ring me
ring I'll have a spine ring we're going
to control the guideline and Lolita head
okay so if you look at the static
version where I have to come around her
head is find an offer for long
when we sophisticated got rid of the
morning public model what it does is
bring her back later
so she comes in
he's allowing me to penetrate through
the hand ring the elbow bringing and
ev'ry I go right that's mine I got all
the but if you're like this just here
you see the hot the head she gets up get
up and fight boom Lucy
okay so let's fake more immediate into
this final ring but don't pull on it in
your lust okay